[Music]  great news I found this new bar called  the shack do you have any idea how many  hot [ __ ] are gonna do that what are  you doing the rest of the night you just  don't get it home with me if she doesn't  want to get crushed you know just once  [Music]  what are you even talking about  I'm ready to get this on I'm not up for  this Haley gets nice with one of you  it's not the cute one  give her hell oh my god found it bro  chicks dig eight guys  if you're the gay guy you're what if she  thinks you're gay you can't close chicks  love to cuddle one thing leads to  another boom they're trying to change  I'm cold  can we cut off yeah absolutely  I'm gonna grab some lunch gotta get my  nails did being gazed so much worse  [Applause]  I think I broke my ass bone oh god I  think all heard me straight  what's so weird I should put it in your  ass since that's what I'm used to  I'm sorry of course of course I'm just  I'm just trying to get through this the  best I can  you